Here, the correct solutions are positive 3 and positive 6. That's amazing
effort if you got these two solutions. Now, don't worry if you got stuck or
don't quite understand this at all, this is only our first practice problem.
Maybe you were able to get the substitution of X minus 2, or maybe even found
the values of U. Let's go through the solution together, pause it where you
think you made your first mistake, and then see if you can solve for these
answers. To perform the U-substitution here, we're going to substitute this
repeated expression, x minus 2, with the variable u. So we'll have u squared
minus 5 times u plus 4. This is the critical step that turns this equation into
a much easier quadratic equation to factor and solve. We factored this using u
minus 4 times u minus 1, and then we solve for u. U can equal 4, or u can equal
1. Nice effort if you found these two variables. But remember we're not done.
We use the substitution u equals x minus 2 so we need to plug in x minus 2 back
in for u to find the original values of x. So if u equals 4 and u equals 1 then
we know x minus 2 must equal 4... And we know x minus 2 must also equal 1. Now
we just add 2 to both sides for each equation to get x equals 6 and x equals 3,
our final solution set.